We are here with Lily and Zach Mascio
and they have come to us with a design dilemma
for their bedroom.
We heard their story.
I'm very nervous right now
because I...
I just hope you like it.
I'm sure we'll love it.
Okay, well we'll-- Let's see.
All right, this is what your bedroom looks like now.
Yeah.
Are you ready?
Yes.
All right, let's see it.
(upbeat music)
(audience gasping and cheering)
Wow.
(audience applauding)
It looks great.
I love it.
Come on in guys.
So...
I'm crying again.
Thank you.
It's so pretty.
Yeah, it's wonderful.
Oh God, thank God.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Oh, look how cute.
Yeah, the single--
I love it, it's so cool.
Absolutely.
And actually one of the first states
that we ever went, we went on a hike.
You took out your camera.
Yeah.
It's like you knew.
Okay, good.
I did something that I don't normally do,
was I tried to design a lot for you, Zach.
Yeah.
I have a little game area
so that you guys can like chill and have a glass of wine
and play some backgammon
and be like, do we wanna talk about kids
or not talk about kids?
Here is where I have an example
of the pops of black that have been inspiring me in design.
I thought I would bring it in
with whether it's the hardware of the lamp
or the material of the poof
or the frames and the photography.
That's also something that I've never done on the show,
was bring a lot of photography
because I thought that in your bedroom,
which has nothing on the walls right now.
That you could stare into photographs
that were a little sexy
and a little mysterious.
And weren't so obvious
and had a touch of sort of an androgynous approach
so that it could speak to you.
And I thought, you know,
you don't need a frilly bedroom.
Thank you.
Honestly.
(laughing)
What you guys need is a sexy suite to escape to.
Thank you very much.
It's incredible.
It's so cool.
It really is.
(audience applauding)
It's wonderful.
It's so cool.
I wanted to bring in some wovens,
a nice sort of like hide rug.
A really-- This bed detail actually--
Really, look how beautiful this is.
Ooh, I love that.
Headboards are always hidden by pillows,
nobody thinks about that.
But so when your pillows are down
you have a nice headboard that has like a nice woven touch
but it's pretty with the pillows and without.
I kind of was inspired by amber tones to go with the black.
And I thought, you know what?
I would love if you guys would come into your bedroom
and feel like you were in a sexy,
almost hotel that you owned.
I can totally see what--
Like, yeah, I see it, it's so cool.
I love it.
And I also got
you guys this mirror,
which I really loved because it's just--
Yin yang.
The yin and yang that make that full circle
which is really, you know, who you guys are and for you.
So what do you think?
It's so cool, I love it.
It's wonderful, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Fantastic.
Thank you.
I'm like stopping myself from like seeing
what a real bed's like again.
I probably may not be able to get up.
That's fine, you don't have to it's your bed now.
This the usual side.
I wanna say thank you to our--
(audience laughing)
Our design team 'cause we just--
I mean, we literally placed every piece of art
and every piece of furniture
and built mood board after mood board.
And we were like, oh, we bought all this art
and like put it up.
And we were like, it's not enough.
(audience laughing)
More!
Everything in here, every single thread and detail,
it is all yours.
It's going home with you, obviously.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Light your candles and enjoy your new bedroom.
Oh, thank you.
Like I could totally hug you.
Why not?
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Oh this is so nice.
Thank you so much.
I can't wait.
I love the couch.
Good! He likes the couch.
Good, okay.
I love the couch.
Thank you, Lily and Zach, truly.
(upbeat music)